[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
good afternoon from my far right
we have miss kelly cummings director of
state operations
to her left beth garvey special counsel
to my right
dr howard zucker commissioner of the
department of health to my left melissa
derosa secretary to the governor to her
left robert
mahika budget director
of the state of new york mta board
member
cuny board member many hats good news
today
overall state positivity rate 3.53
75 statewide deaths
still after all this time we still have
new yorkers dying 75
those families are in our thoughts and
prayers
statewide hospitalizations are down 46.
i see you down
29 intubations down 12. this is great
news
this is great news remember what
happened
we hit the holiday season we talked
about it
thanksgiving holiday season 37 days
kwanzaa hanukkah christmas more social
gatherings the number would go up
the number did go up january 4th it
peaks
when you think about it holiday season
is over new year's
day new year's eve it peaks
and it has continually dropped but it
has
dropped to a level
below where it was before it started to
peak
okay so christmas
a little bit after thanksgiving but
before we saw any big increase we're
about 6 600
go up to 8 000 and now we're down to
5 400. so we've really made
tremendous progress and this is really
really good news
it's not over and we have to continue
but this is very very good news
percent of hospitalized is down across
the state and that's all good news new
york city is the highest at 0.04
right now covet positivity
which plus a minus relates to the
hospitalization long island
new york mid-hudson long island new york
mid-hudson
what people should get from these slides
with these numbers ask yourself
why is there such a variance
within one state
why is there such a variance in
demographic areas that are basically
very similar why is central new york
uh mid hudson why is mid hudson four
times higher than central new york
right uh these areas
same state same basic demographics
it is about behavior it is about
behavior
it's about what we do you take western
new york 1.9
western new york for weeks
was a trouble area and now it's 1.9
because the community changed the
community adapted the community heard
and this is a function of personal
behavior and that's why you're seeing
these variances
across the state you look at new york
city the bronx is down
where it was but five percent it's
double manhattan
staten island which was an aberration is
now more in line but
staten island bronx queens are all about
the same
it is about behavior vaccines we have
big
news just under 5 million vaccines done
overall really good news
we had a white house called yesterday
johnson and johnson vaccine
has arrived in new york this is
uh from a practical point of view
not a medical point of view uh
much easier than the fisa modern
vaccines it's one shot you don't have to
come back for a second shot you don't
have to schedule a second shot it
doesn't take a second appointment
and there's no cold storage for the
johnson and johnson
uh so it's a very big deal we
are expecting an initial tranche
of about 164 000 doses and
i'll explain in a moment what i mean by
first tranche
uh this first tranche
which is large will be administered
by radically ramping
up the vaccination system
we had the fisa moderna we were
scaled to the fisa moderna on top
of that the federal government then adds
about 160 000 doses which is a lot of
doses
for the state so we needed
a extra ramp up of
actual vaccination operations because of
this
johnson and johnson influx it's good
news
but we have to uh then
get it in arms as soon as possible uh
we've taken a number of measures
uh but among them are mass vaccination
sites
yankee stadium javits state fair they're
going to go to 24
7. i want to thank the staff very much
that is willing to do that because that
is a big deal and these are staffed at a
stretch to begin with
but they'll go to 24 7 you can make an
appointment
that will only last for the duration
of that initial first large
tranche of johnson johnson
after that first tranche of johnson
johnson
the production is actually going to slow
and lag
and then build back up again so we have
this
one time blip one time
large tranche good news then it will
slow
then it will ramp up again but i'll ask
kelly cummings who's been doing a great
job
uh getting these mass vaccination sites
to transfer to 24 7
and ask kelly if she has any additional
comments
sure um yankee stadium
will begin operations tomorrow night
thursday night
the appointments open this morning
it will be operating with the johnson
and johnson vaccine during the overnight
hours
as the governor said as the supply lasts
the javits center in new york city new
york state fairgrounds in syracuse
they will be in operations on friday
night and appointments will open
tomorrow
thursday at 8 a.m for those two sites
how many nights will these sites open 24
hours seven
we're not clear yet it's going to depend
on how many people
come in for the vaccine i know there's a
pent up demand
i believe people will show up in the
middle of the night to get the vaccine
but we're talking uh
several days to a week
in that range and then once we run
out of the initial tranche of johnson
johnson
then it will basically scale back down
we're also using other mechanisms to get
out the additional doses
pharmacies fqhcs local health
departments and hospitals
because remember on top of the johnson
johnson we also have an
increase in the fisa moderna
vaccines the biden administration has
increased
the percentage of vaccines about 70
percent
since they've taken office it's really
amazing what he has done
but again the johnson johnson increase
is a one-time infusion
then a brief lag in production then an
increase
the overall picture is that president
says
the vaccine supply for all americans by
the end of
may now that was the it was the end of
july
he's now moving it up to the end of may
and that is a very significant
increase apparently using the defense
production
act they have accelerated the production
of the vaccine
and johnson johnson and merck have
formed a
partnership so merck is going to help
produce a johnson and johnson vaccine
normally drug companies don't play nice
like this but the president used the
defense production act
this is going to dramatically increase
the production this is what's allowing
them to move up the schedule
until may president also says
prioritize teachers and he wants the
states
and then the local governments directed
by the states
to prioritize teachers
i believe president biden is right we
need children back
in classrooms children not in classrooms
hurts the child that hurts their
socialization
it puts additional stress on the family
every
expert will say it as soon as you can
get children back in the classroom get
them back in the classroom
we have classrooms where the infection
rate is much
lower than the surrounding community the
teachers
need and deserve a right to feel
safe they do
and even before president biden said
this
i said last week local governments must
report on how many teachers are
vaccinated
and coordinate with the school districts
to report how many teachers are in the
classrooms
in other words i believe
a teacher could say i want a vaccine
before i go into the classroom
okay how many teachers have we
vaccinated and how many
are in classrooms for cities this
information is easy
to gather because the city is
co-terminus with the school district
other areas you'll have school districts
overlapping
counties so uh
they'll have to call the school
districts and get the data but this is
president
biden's point he wants a prioritization
of vaccination for
teachers because he wants teachers in
the classroom
now you have a lot of prioritizations
going on
in this vaccination process nursing home
residents were prioritized
nursing home staff was prioritized
hospital staff was prioritized police
teachers school teachers so
we have a long priority list but i think
the president
is right this is about getting kids back
into the classroom
overall covert rates are down as we just
went through
vaccine rates are up so we continue the
smart reopening
right the graphic that nobody likes
what we have done which has been very
smart from day one
uh report reopen
based on science and data i feel this i
feel that
feelings are nice facts are better
and we have been calibrating by the
science and the data
on the covert emergency powers we've
worked with the legislature
uh we have an agreement on a bill
where the legislature can repeal any
executive order
that i issue with over 50 percent
both houses the covert emergency powers
continue past april 30th when we first
did this we thought the
we thought the pandemic would be open
over april 30th
this is a year ago we said about a year
at that time it was implausible to think
it was going to go beyond the year
it's gone beyond the year and it's not
going to end by april 30th so they're
going to extend
the legislation extends the emergency
power
to the point where the federal
government declares an end to the
pandemic
which the federal government does it
controls funds etc
we have more time in this situation by
and large
we'll give the legislature notice of any
changes that we're making prior
five days prior to effect if it is an
emergency
change as determined by department of
health
uh then it will be a shorter period of
time
um i don't remember exactly what it was
do you remember what it was beth he will
give notice as soon as possible
okay uh and during the five days
there'll be legislative consultant
consultation on the change orders
that we make during the five days and
again
whatever order i put in place the
legislature can repeal it
in 24 hours or whenever they
choose and that's always been the way
travel guidance domestic travelers are
no longer required to quarantine or test
out within the 90 days of full
vaccination
international travelers you have to
continue to follow the cdc
quarantine guidelines gathering limits
we're going to change
and let me go to rob who's done a lot of
work on this
so beginning march 22nd on for
residential gatherings the indoor limits
remains the same
outdoor limit goes to from 10 to 25
outdoor which is consistent with
some of the states around us the social
gathering limit
for public spaces
on indoor events goes from 50 to
100 and then for outdoor events it will
go from 50
to 200.
so all of those will still also require
social distancing as well as mass
requirements
and then beginning on april 2nd we've
started with opening large event spaces
which was 10 000 or more for arenas
starting with the buffalo bills
subsequent to that
last night the rangers had a couple of
thousand people at their game
nets last saturday also held a
basketball game um
using those guidelines that we got from
the buffalo bills
so following from that for event spaces
that are less than
10 000 uh those can begin reopening
at 33 capacity with up to 100 people
indoors and again 200 people outdoors
again there still will be guidance for
social distancing and
uh masks if we want to go above those
limits
you can go up to 150 people indoor with
testing requirements for going from 100
to 150
and then for outdoor events up to 500
people
outdoors uh with testing and again
social distancing
and face covering will be required uh by
all of the attendees rob can you please
mention the empire pass
program so on the empire pass program so
we
uh have an app that we have been working
with
working with ibm on that app
you when you get tested uh if with your
consent
the results of that test can be reported
automatically to the app and then you
can then
show proof of a negative test upon
entrance to any of these events that
require
testing that app has been tested right
now
both at barclays and at
madison square garden and those tests
have been
successful uh so once we get the
approvals though the app will be
available for uh download
on both platforms on google and apple
platforms people download to their
smartphones
and that will allow someone to show uh
the result of their test whether it be a
pcr test
uh which will give which we valid for up
to 72 hours
or if rapid test which we valid for six
hours in addition though if you don't
want to have use an app
you will be able to download a paper
result of your test that you can then
print out
and use that to demonstrate your
negative test so again these are all
this was all
tested started with the bills games it
has been tested at the two events
uh recently most recent one as late as
early as
uh last night and that will be
available and we'll start rolling that
out again beginning within a week
and those and you can use that to
go to some of these events when we want
to get to the larger numbers like i said
to go
to 250 for indoor events
or up to 500 people for outdoor events
great thank you very much robert uh
foundation to reopening we talk a lot
about reopening and the valves and the
getting the economy back foundation to
reopening is
public safety people don't think of it
that way
but a community is not going to thrive
if people don't feel
safe after the george floyd
murder we have had localities
working on reforming their
public safety plans mr floyd's
death was really just a
a point where there was an explosion of
frustration
and we said to every local government
we're not telling you what to do but if
you have a public safety department you
have to put everyone at the table have a
collaborative come up with
a reform public safety plan cities are
doing
fantastic work and creative
work uh but not all of them are doing it
if they don't do it and we get to the
budget
then the they're going to be significant
sanctions on the city
uh please you have 29 days
i know it's a hard topic i know people
would rather stay away from it
but public safety is one of the top
priorities
for any mayor for any county executive
any supervisor
public safety is a top priority yes it's
hard yes it's sticky yes it's
controversial
but it's also the job
the light at the end of the tunnel is in
sight
but we can't stop driving now
this we've had critical moments all
through this period
but this is one of the most critical
moments
in my opinion we have a number of things
going on
we have a massive rap ramp up of the
vaccine
operation by may when president biden
says
oh by the way i've found the way to
produce
millions more doses that's great news
but now you have to ramp up a
vaccination
operation that goes from
the end of july to may in a very large
state which is what new york is that's a
challenge
the variants are still here
don't think that there isn't
an ever present danger
and these variants are not just here the
variants
are created all the time
the virus mutates all the time
and it's very possible that there's a
mutation to the virus
that is going to require a different
type of booster
shot that's why this is so important
to get all those vaccines done now
because the vaccines can protect you
from the variant
but that is a lingering danger we're
dealing with
and then you have the new york recovery
rebuilding
and finances uh you know
when you deal with a storm the first
step is the emergency response to the
storm there's a hurricane
keep everybody safe get people in out of
the cold
second step is the water recedes
and now you see the damage that you have
to
rebuild the damage to this state
to this city is extraordinary
and we're going to have a lot of work to
do
and this is all happening at the same
time
environmentally we can't relax
too soon i get it
copic fatigue everybody wants everybody
wants
the all restrictions gone
everybody does yes but you also have to
be smart
about the reopening in my opinion
some states are going too far too fast
and that is a danger because covet is
still a risk
and you relax those restrictions too far
you will see the beast rise
up again smart
new york tough smart
united disciplined loving
let me make an unrelated
announcement if i can
i want to address the recent allegations
that have been made
against me as you probably know the
attorney general is doing an independent
review
and i will fully cooperate with that
review
now the lawyers say i shouldn't say
anything
when you have a pending review until
that review is over
i understand that i'm a lawyer too
but i want new yorkers
to hear from me directly on this
first i fully
support a woman's right to come forward
and i think it should be encouraged in
every way
i now understand that i
acted in a way that made people
feel uncomfortable
it was unintentional and i
truly and deeply apologize for it
i feel awful
about it and frankly
i am embarrassed by
it and that's not easy to say
but that's the truth but this is what i
want you
to know and i want you to know this from
me directly i
never touched anyone inappropriately
i never touched anyone inappropriately
i never knew at the time
that i was making anyone feel
uncomfortable i never knew
at the time i was making anyone feel
uncomfortable and
i certainly never ever
meant to offend anyone
or hurt anyone or cause
anyone any pain
that is the last thing i would ever want
to do
i asked the people of this state
to wait for the facts from the attorney
general's report before forming
an opinion
get the facts please before
forming an opinion and the attorney
general is doing
that review i will fully cooperate
with it and then you will have the facts
and make a decision when you know the
facts
i also want you to know that
i have learned from what has been
an incredibly difficult
situation for me
as well as other people and i've learned
an important lesson i'm sorry
i'm sorry for whatever pain i caused
anyone
i never intended it
and i will be the better for this
experience
thank you questions
thank you governor we would like to ask
a question please use the raise hand
function at the bottom of your window
we'll take a brief moment to compile the
q a roster
governor your first question comes from
marcia cramer of wcbs
marcia your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
governor can you hear me marcia craim of
the dean
of the delegation so governor i have
actually two questions first of all i
wonder
if even the distractions of these two
investigations especially the one
loving sexual harassment you feel that
you might want to step aside or that you
should step aside especially
in negotiating the budget which could be
one of the most important budgets that
the state has ever had to
deal with and my second question has to
do with the pictures that have surfaced
of you uh touching a few of
the reason i'm asking the question is
that i've also seen speculated pictures
of you touching the faces of people all
over the state
young and old whatever and i wonder what
you make of those pictures
yeah uh thank you very much marcia let
me take both questions first
you're right about the state budget it
is critically important
the state budget is going to turn the
page to the rebuilding
phase we've been working very hard to
get funding from washington
to fill the gap and
that has been going well we have to see
what we actually get
but we then have tremendous financial
needs on top of that people have to pay
the rent they need food etc
uh you also have new york city which is
in a very precarious
situation uh it's uh
teetering to use a word crime is way up
homelessness is way up many people have
left
new york city
hamptons mid hudson valley other states
we have to get new york city
functional again and safe again
and viable again and we have to do that
quickly
we have a new mayor that's going to be
selected basically in june
i guess something could happen in
november but basically in june
and that work has to start right away so
yes the budget is very important
i mean just step aside though and let
somebody else handle it yeah having said
that
i'm going to cooperate with the attorney
general's investigation
and do the budget remember we did a
budget
last year in the spring in the heat
of coded where it was the most intense
period of my life of this government's
life of this state's life
and we did both and we'll do both here
on the pictures marcia
uh i understand the uh
opinion of uh and feelings of ms uh
rua and you are right
you can find uh hundreds of
pictures of me uh
making the same gesture with hundreds
of people women men children
etc uh
you can go find hundreds of pictures of
me
kissing people men women
it is my usual and customary way
of greeting you know that because
you've watched me for let's just say
more years than we care to remember by
the way it was my father's way of
greeting people you're the governor of
the state
you want people to feel comfortable you
want to reach out to them
uh i i do it
i kissed and hugged legislators i was at
an event in queens the other day
i hugged the pastors and the the uh
assembly members who were there so that
is my way to do that
however what i also understand
is it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
my intent uh
what matters is if anybody was offended
by it and
i could intend no offense but if they
were offended by
it then it was wrong and if they were
offended by
it i apologize and if they
were hurt by it i apologize
and if they felt pain from it i
apologize
i apologize i did not intend it
i didn't mean it that way
but if that's how they felt that's all
that matters and i apologize
next question operator
governor your next question comes from
dave evans
from wabc dave your line is now
open please unmute your
jacob microphone hear me okay yeah dave
i just wanted to ask you um with all
these calls in the last couple of days
calling for your resignation from stone
democrats certainly not all democrats
but some democrats
it is today since you've been gone for
about a week
is this your way of saying
i'm certainly not resigning yeah
dave uh look uh some politicians will
always play
politics right that's the nature of the
beast uh i don't think today is a day
for politics
uh i wasn't elected by politicians i was
elected by the people of the state of
new york
i'm not going to resign i worked for the
people of the state of new york they
elected me
and i'm going to serve the people of the
state of new york and by the way we have
a full
plate we have covert we have recovery we
have rebuilding
we have a teetering new york city we
have a terrible financial picture
we have to do vaccines so
no i'm going to
do the job the people of the state
elected me to do
next question operator
governor your next question comes from
andrew siff of wnbc
andrew your line is now open please
emute your microphone
governor good afternoon two questions
the first is
given how contrite you've been today
why did it take a week for you to go
before the cameras when people have
noted
your absence for so many days my second
question is
what assurances can you provide new
yorkers
that there are not other accusers who
worked for you
who will lodge similar complaints to the
two that have already been
alleged yeah two things andrew the
uh i i apologized
uh several days ago i apologize today
i will apologize tomorrow i will
apologize
the day after uh
and i want new yorkers to understand
because this is
more the the facts will come out in the
attorney general's review but i want
them to understand the emotion
because it's really for me it's
as much about the emotion i never knew
at the time that i was making anyone
feel uncomfortable
i never ever meant to offend anyone or
hurt anyone
or cause anyone pain i feel
terrible that
these people felt
uncomfortable felt hurt felt pain
from the interactions
i'm embarrassed by it and i feel bad by
from it
i'm not in this business to make people
uh feel uncomfortable i'm here to make
them
to help them that's the essence of what
i do what i do
um the
[Music]
uh i do not believe i have ever done
anything in my public career that
i uh i'm ashamed of
uh i didn't know
uh i was making uh um
her un uncomfortable at the time i feel
badly that i did
uh but and i'm i'm gonna learn
from it marcia asked me about you know
my usual custom
is to kiss and to hug and and make that
gesture
i understand that sensitivities have
changed and
behavior has changed and i get it and
i'm going to learn from it
next question
governor your next question comes from
karina jerry of wutr
karina your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
thank you governor hi how are you good
how are you
i'm good so i actually have two
questions
um my first one is if a member of your
administration
had done what you are currently accused
of and had
and have admitted to what would you tell
them and what would be
a satisfactory disposition for you
well let's be clear on the facts first
uh we haven't gotten the facts let the
attorney general
do a review and let's get the facts and
that's what i said uh
in my statement to new yorkers i'm a
former attorney general i've been
through a situation too many times where
uh everybody has an opinion because they
read this they read this
and then all of a sudden the facts come
out and it's a different situation so
wait for the facts before you form an
opinion
uh and as i said my my behavior here
uh i never touched anyone
inappropriately
i never knew at the time that i was
making anyone feel uncomfortable
and if i ever did make
people feel uncomfortable which
i now understand that i have i apologize
for it
but then let the attorney general's
office actually review the facts
yes thank you thank you thank you
next question operator
governor your next question comes from
jeff kulakowski of wsyr
jeff your line is now open please unmute
your microphone
um hi governor um i was curious and i
know you
said uh and apologized uh several times
this afternoon
who were you apologizing to
i was apologizing to the
young woman who worked here who said
that i made her feel
uncomfortable um
and in the workplace
were you were you also speaking to new
yorkers governor
oh to new yorkers i uh
i'm saying that um
[Music]
i'm embarrassed by what happened
uh my i wear a pin
that says uh pride integrity performance
that's that's what it says on the pin
you can't read it
pride integrity performance uh
so i'm embarrassed that someone uh
felt that way in my administration i'm
embarrassed
and hurt and i apologize that
uh somebody who interacted with me felt
that way
uh again uh i didn't know at the time
i was making her feel uncomfortable i
never meant to
but but that doesn't matter if a person
feels
uncomfortable if a person feels pain
if a person is offended i feel very
badly about that
and i apologize for it
there's no but you know it's
i'm sorry
let's take one more question operator
governor your next question comes from
jennifer lukey of whec
jennifer your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
good afternoon governor i actually have
two questions one for you and one for
melissa
governor um have you yourself taken the
sexual harassment
training required by new york that all
employers are to give
to their employees and melissa as the
highest ranking woman
in state government right now and
someone who interacts with the governor
on a daily basis how do you feel about
these allegations
against him and what is your message to
women
who see you in your position and see
these allegations against the governor
short answer is yes uh
and i'll turn it over to uh melissa just
keep in mind um there are hundreds and
hundreds of people who
work with melissa we have more senior
women in this administration than
probably
any administration in history but
i'll ask melissa to respond
again i would just ask that everyone
refrain from judgment
until the attorney general is allowed to
do her work
we've asked her to come in everyone's
going to fully comply with that
but i am incredibly proud of the work
that this administration has done to
further women's rights
to expand protections for women in the
workplace
out of the workplace maternal health
reproductive health the list goes on and
on and on and i'm also proud
that in my time as secretary we've seen
more women rise to highest levels in
terms of commissioners
and senior staff levels and we've
promoted each other and we've supported
one another
and i don't think that this diminishes
any of that and i look forward to
continuing the work that we're doing in
order to continue to further the women's
agenda and strengthen women's rights for
all new yorkers
okay thank you all very much have a good
day
covered numbers are good still be smart
thank you
you
you